eca didier destremau ancien diplomate
auteur de le roman de la série aux
éditions du rocher bonsoir didier des
très beaux mercier d'être avec nous vous
craignez vous pensez possible également
ce péril imminent d'une escalade
on met en garde le responsable de l'onu
moi je vois que erdogan
et puis d'embarras là la perte de digues
libre
la défaite des des rebelles et de
djihadistes qui sont concentrés les
dribbles et se défait de de la turquie
lundi visiblement mais d'un côté je
crois pas car de gan soit capable de
désobéir à poutine
il a trop besoin il est très isolé il a
peu trop besoin de l'appui de la russie
il est en mal avec la france tout le
monde le sait il est à couteaux tirés
avec les états unis
pourtant qui sont dans l'otan avec lui
et donc il est tout seul je crois pas
qu'il qu'il irait au pirée qu'il
attaquerait directement avec ces soldats
turcs les avec les supplétifs syrien qui
dépendent de lui peut-être commis fait
olivier maintenant mais directement avec
arrêté avec l'armé tueur je crois pas
mais alors quel est l'intérêt de ces
menaces
pour ankara les menaces parce que
d'abord c'est le style d'erdogan
il me laisse tout le monde il a menacé
macron n'y a pas très longtemps il me
laisse le mot de la menace est remplacée
mais aussi c'est peut-être aussi c'est
peut-être la marque d'une certaine
panique ils sont hyper ils sont que son
investissement en envahissant le nord de
la syrie en appuyant les les rebelles et
la est en fête
les djihadistes comme l'a fait pendant
des années en sueur et est en train est
unie est une politique et une stratégie
qui est en train de perdre donc
peut-être que sa folle et qu'il est
excessif à cause de son affolement alors
moscou en tout cas met en garde ankara
concrètement qu'est ce que ça peut
donner ankara va se faire obéir moscou
qu'elle peut être justement la position
vous le dit un peu un peu fébrile delà
de la turquie un peu difficile c'est
difficile de de prévoir mais je crois
que pour l'instant dogan dans l'embarras
il hausse le ton
mais je crois je répète une fois encore
qu'il n'osera pas passer à l'action
c'est trop grave vis-à-vis de la série
devait vous avez de delà de la russie
pardon je crois pas car dogan soit assez
musclée pour se poser de francs à ce que
veut poutine ses adhérents c'est à dire
i l'éradication de la poche d'idlib et
la victoire finale de son poulain bachar
el-assad
alors il ya eu un conseil de sécurité de
l'onu aujourd'hui sur ce sujet la russie
s'est opposée à l'adoption par le
conseil de sécurité d'une déclaration
réclamant une cessation des hostilités
le respect du droit international
humanitaire proposée d'ailleurs par la
france
quelle est la stratégie russe pourquoi
ce refus
moi je crois que d'abord les rues sont
très contents de voir la turquie membre
éminent de l'otan quitté un petit peu
c'est un mouvement se otanienne donc
c'est diviser l'ouest divisé l'occident
ça donc c'est une tactique tout à fait
compréhensible de la part de poutine
de l'autre côté la victoire de bachar
el-assad et le calme
l'instabilité revenu en syrie plus de
menaces du côté de l'église plus de
djihadistes qui peut faire le va et
vient entre la syrie et la turquie
ça sert des intérêts de delà de la
russie qui souhaite maintenant calmer le
jeu et que ses relations avec la syrie
et avec le vent en général
des relations apaisées de normal la
russie est elle restée justement
larbitre de la situation la marge de
manoeuvre est encore assez élevé pour
moscou à mon avis la russie l'est déjà
depuis longtemps
larbitre 1 la russie s'est implantée au
levant à achat c'est pratiquement tous
les autres ne parlons pas de la france
on n'y est plus les états unis n'est pas
ce qu'une chose c'est à s'en tirer et
donc la russie est seulement doucement
les arbitres mais la maîtresse du jeu
aujourd'hui la réunion la région d'idlib
et quand même au coeur des tensions avec
ankara est ce que je reviens de ma
première question est ce que il ya une
crainte quand même que ce conflit qui
s'élargissent la difficulté vous vous
mettez le doigt dessus c'est que erdogan
veut pas perdre la face donc il sera
obligé de d'assumer une certaine action
pour dire qu'ils se replient ou que il a
laissé libre tomber volontairement que
ce soit décision que son choix
donc il veut il a il est habile est en
difficulté il n'y a pas de doute mais il
faut encore je crois pas qu'on en vienne
aux mains entre l'armée série d'un côté
la mer de l'autre et aussi le sort des
réfugiés très nombreux 900000 on
comprendre que la turquie puisse être
plus qu'embarrassé par ce sujet
oui et non je crois que l'afflux de
réfugiés passés et actuels en turquie
est à une carte à tous dans les mains de
deux heures de garde à vue gav peut nous
faire chanter nous les européens en
disant si vous si vous ne nous appuyer
passé votre départ solution si vous
n'agissez pas auprès de bachar el-assad
je vais vous faire envahir temps les
réfugiés donc en définitive c'est une
carte qui peut jouer en faveur d'air de
garde
mais il est vrai que déjà en russie en
turquie à environ 3 millions de réfugiés
syriens c'est beaucoup et or
ajouter un million ça serait peut-être
excessif et la supportable pour la
population turque
on a parlé du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu qui s'est tenue ce soir ce qui a
clairement un rôle que peut jouer l'onu
la communauté internationale dans ce
dossier ça sera ma dernière question à
partir du moment où conseil de sécurité
il ya cinq pays qui est en droit de veto
dont la russie et la chine qui
s'opposeront bien évidemment un tout
petit défi active occidental tu crois
que le conseil de sécurité peut juste
discuter faire du bla bla bla mais ne
pas adopter deux résolutions qui
s'imposerait ni à la turquie bien sûr
erdogan s'en fiche complètement
mais à la russie remercie beaucoup
didier extrêmement aux anciens
diplomates auteur du roman de la série
aux éditions du rocher d'avoir été avec
nous